[Musica]
una buona sera di ritrovati saluto si
stanno vendendo perché dire no quella
casti da un paio di giorni ostaggio di
tre gabbiano che chiamo lory questa io
giuro non ce la faccio più praticamente
sai che sta traslocando no stata avanti
e indietro per milano tutto il giorno
dopo sette volte un aromatizza senso
come stai
[Musica]
prendo come un male va bene cosa
vogliamo fare qualcosa vogliamo uscire
vuoi andare fuori a cena c'è un
ristorante molto carino qua vicino
attiva
[Musica]
vogliamo andare fuori a cena si o no
proprio no preparazione va bene allora
finiamo ordiniamo qualcosa udito suu kyi
momento sfida
come diavolo fa il paganica possibile
che tu possa vincere anche ogni singola
partita di sonorità del sud riesce a
vincere se sono salite del tour
maledettissime maryza nessuno sa come
sito a questo ma lentissimo gioco lo
abbiamo capito va bene non è che
possiamo tipo giocare tutti insieme con
il es
[Musica]
una roba inebria un po di macchinari
saluti finali grazie a tutti lungo il
sole dai dai
tocca a te tocca a te ma devi far male
al solito i cimiteri terzi e foro
aiutatelo aiutato possibile così non è
il problema parte vabbè ci siamo
divertiti così può bastare
basta me ne vado via basterà ragazza
andiamo di questa devi fare
quindi ragazzi questi sono i miei testi
che sono eco che tipo il nome di pietro
ma fa niente
shockwave turbine è quello che in mano
in this moment and commander sono quelli
che utilizzato in questo video comunque
ragazzi potete lanciare i vostri tardi
con i nerd fino a 27 metri è la cosa
molto molto divertente potete utilizzare
anche questi che sono i vari lotti con
un punteggio sopra il punteggio serve
per vedere se fatevi punti ovviamente no
ci vediamo presto grazie per averci
video video il sile della canale in
bacino a tutti tranne gli amici che se
ne sono andati bene
[Musica]